THEM TO LEAPFROGCTIVE
CONSECUTIVE GAME IN TWO PRIOR
GA BARABANOV TO THE ZONE, CAN'T
GET TO THE NET BUT GETS IT AWAYL
13-GAME POINT STREAK RIGHT FIFTH
TIME McDAVID,
29th GAME, GOAU CAN'T MAKE
HAVE TO USE INDIRECT PASS OFF
THE BOARDS IN BEHIND THE
FORECHECKER THAT PIC MAYBE
WITH HIS GEAR ONE SHARKS
HERTL SETS UP.
BACK FOR
MEIER TAKES IT, HAS A LOOK
DROPS FOR BURNS. IN FRONT FROM N
COUTURE.
AND REEDY STEERS IT IN.
>> Bret: DIDN'T GET BACK TO THE
HERE LINE, HAD TO GE
HOLDING ON TO PLAYS AND
EXTENDING THEM OUT
>> Randy: WITH NO REBOUND
DARNELL NURSE JOUSTING A BITURE
UP WITH IT, TURNED BACK OVER TID
PULJUJARVI WITH A CHANCE THERE
>> RandyED IT AWAY, CLEARED BY
OILERS AND ANOTHER, TAKEI THOUGD
HAVE PULLED THE TRIGGER, HE GOES
DOWN THE WALL, MISSES THE STICK.
BARABANOV TRIES TO DANGLE AROUND
THE EDMONTON DEFENDER KULAK.
SHARKS STILL H H
MERKLEY, CHANGINTHE SHARKS CAN T
THIS KILLED OFF.
BEEN GOOD ON SPECIAL TEAMS AND
TRYING TO GET IT FROM HIM, LOST
AN EDGE.
BONINO WILL PUSH THIS  AIR
LOOK AT BALCERS' OPPORTUNIA TWOE
GOAL SCORING SHARKS GET
ANOTHER PUCK TO THE NET AND BIG
TWO-ON-ONE WITH HYMAN AND THEYDL
HELSSON
PASS
DOESN'T EXECUTE ON THAT ONE.
>> Randy: HYMAN AND NURSE WITH
UP
SEE IF HIS E
THIRD.
CECI
UP THROUGH CENTER.
YAMAMOTO TIES UP THERE WITH
FERRARO.
AND IT'SD THAT TO
THE OTHER SIDE: DEPENDING WHERET
NOW WE'LL SORT THIS OU